[موسيقى]
الصين باتت اليوم قوه عالميه ذات نفوذ
وتاثير لم يصدر هذا الوصف عن الرئيس
الصيني شي جيم بينك ولا عن مسؤول في
حكومته وانما اطلقه وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي في عرض الاستراتيجيه بلاده تجاه
الصين وقد اعتبرها الدوله الوحيده التي
تنوي اعاده تشكيل النظام الدولي واتهمها
بالعمل على تقويض القوانين والمبادئ
والمؤسسات التي مكنتها من تحقيق نموها
الاقتصادي وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه الذي
يعتزم زياره الصين بعد ايام معدودات اوضح
اخيرا في تصريحات بالرياض بان بلاده لا
تخير احدا بينها وبين بيجين وانما تحاول
اظهار فوائد الشراكه معها تلقفت الخارجيه
الصينيه هذا التصريح مؤكده ضروره اقتران
الاقوال الامريكيه بالافعال دعيه واشنطن
الى التوقف عن نشر ما وصفتها بالمعلومات
المضلله عن الصين وعن توجيه الضربات الى
الش الصينيه تقول واشنطن لا يوجد ما يمنع
الدولتين من التعايش السلمي والمساهمه معا
في التقدم البشري لانه هناك دعوات في
اروقه الى تبني سياسه اكثر صرامه
امريكيون من ان المواجهه بين القوتين
قادمه لا محاله والسؤال متى يتحدثون عن
حرب بارده جديده تفاصيل لجعل منطقه الشرق
الاوسط جبهه رئيسيه فيها في قصتنا الصين
وامريكا الفرص والتحديات نرصد التنافس بين
القوتين على هذه المنطقه التي تضم اكبر
عدد من مشاريع مبادره الحزام والطريق
الصينيه واين دفعت الولايات المتحده
باستثمارات تجاوزت عام 2020 واحد وتسعين
مليار دولار نبحث مع خبراء امريكيين
وصينيين ابعاد تمدد نفوذ الصيني في دول
الشرق الاوسط ونستكمل بقيه القصه
الخير احمد الخبير في شؤون الصينيه
وبرايان هاردينج مستشار وزير الدفاع
الامريكي السابق ومسؤول قسم اسيا بمعهد
السلام الامريكي نساله ضيفين الكريمين عن
اسباب ومالات التنافس بين الولايات
المتحده والصين واحتمالات تحوله الى
مواجهه عالميه والى اي حد تتهدد المصالح
الامريكيه بفعل تنام علاقات بيجين لدول
الشرق الاوسط عن فرص التي يوفرها التنافس
بين القوتين لدول المنطقه لكن ما رايكم
قبل ان نبدا الحوار نشاهد القصه
تنافسيه محمومه برزت بشكل لافت في ظل
الحرب على اوكرانيا بين اقطاب القوى
الكبرى وعلى راسها الصين في مقابل واشنطن
وحلفائها لم يخفي قاده مجموعه السبع في
قمتهم المنعقده في مايو 2003
تحذيرهم مما اسموه الاكراه الاقتصادي الذي
تمارسه الصين وقد سبق لقاده المجموعه
اطلاق برنامج بنيه تحتيه في يونيو 2021
بكلفه تزيد عن اربعين تريليون دولار لدعم
الدول الفقيره ومتوسطه الدخل في محاوله
لمواجهه التوسع الاقتصادي الصيني نحو
الدول الناميه لاسيما استثمارات مبادره
الحزام والطريق الصينيه عام 2021 ضمت
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا اكبر
عدد من مشاريع مبادره الحزام والطريق
الصينيه
هي حرب بارده ناعمه ان صح التعبير وتتجلى
في الغالب من خلال الت الاقتصادي هناك
القليل من المنافسه ايضا في حقل
التكنولوجيا لذا فهناك بعض المخاوف اعربت
عنها الولايات المتحده تجاه بعض اقرب
شركائها
[موسيقى]
في الشرق الاوسط تنوي الصين استخدام
قدراتها الخاصه بتشييد البنى التحتيه
ومواردها الاقتصاديه لتنفيذ المشاريع هذا
يصب في مصلحه الصين ودول الشرق الاوسط لكن
الولايات المتحده لا يروخها ان تفعل الصين
ذلك لهذا وضعوا العديد من العراقيين
[موسيقى]
في مدينه تشانكشا التي تعد راس مال الصين
وقوتها يتم انتاج معدات البنيه التحتيه
الثقيله التي تستخدم في جميع انحاء العالم
المدير الاقليمي لشركه
يتفقد اله حفر انفاق سيتم تصديرها الى
الشرق الاوسط
هذا المشروع مهم جدا اذا صارت الامور على
ما يرام قد يساعدنا في سوق اليات حرف
الانفاق في الشرق الاوسط وجنوب شرق اسيا
يستغرق الانتاج في الشركات الغربيه حوالي
ثمانيه اشهر بينما نحن يمكننا اتمام العمل
في غضون ثلاثه اشهر او اربعه وهذا يساعد
شركات البناء في توفير الوقت انها واحده
من نقاط قوتنا
[موسيقى]
لم يعد توسع الصين الاقتصادي في الشرق
الاوسط يقتصر على تصدير المعدات فقد اخذت
شركات صينيه عديده تشارك بشكل مباشر في
تنميه الشرق الاوسط
[موسيقى]
بل وافادت الصين من موقع مصر الفريد
لتوسيع قوتها التجاريه والسياسيه في جميع
انحاء الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا واوروبا في
عام 2010 ولمواجهه قواعد الاتحاد الاوروبي
لمكافحه الاغراق بالالياف الزجاجيه
الصينيه اقرت مجموعه جوشي الصينيه
استراتيجيه التوجه الى الخارج بعدها
بعامين انشات المجموعه اول شركه افريقيه
للالواح الزجاجيه في حديقه تيدا
[موسيقى]
اول حاجه بقول لك ان السولبه هنا الزمن
بتاعها من غير المكنه تطلع ثلاث ثواني لقد
اصبحت جوشي اكبر منتج للالياف الزجاجيه في
العالم في عام 2008 اليوم لدينا 1600 موظف
30 منهم صينيون والباقي مصريون لقد جلبنا
تقنياتنا الاساسيه لاستخدامها في مصر
[موسيقى]
لقد جرب شرق الاوسط الطريقه الغرب وطريقه
الشرق وطريقه السوفيتيه وطريقته الخاصه
وقد وجدوا ان النموذج الصيني يستحق
الاستكشاف وبعد اطلاق مبادره الحزام
والطريق في عام 2013 لقيت الصين ترحيبا
واسعا فالكل يريد ان يصعد في القطار
السريع للتنميه الصينيه
الى اي مدى كان للصين تاثير على علاقه مصر
بالولايات المتحده لا اعتقد ان ذلك قد حدث
حتى الان مصر لا تزال تنظر الى الولايات
المتحده كشريك استراتيجيا وامنيا رئيسي
واعتقد ان امريكا يجب ان تعيد النظر في
نظرتها للدور الذي تلعبه مصر في الاقتصاد
وكذلك في الطاقه وتغير المناخ
في عام 2021 وقعت الصين اتفاقيه تعاون
استراتيجي مع ايران لمده 25 عاما بقيمه
400 مليار دولار بحيث تتلقى الصين امدادا
متواصلا من النفط الايراني
[موسيقى]
سياسيا ازداد اعتماد ايران على الصين
فعلاقاتها مع الولايات المتحده متوتره
وعلاقته مع اوروبا ليست جيده ايضا لهذا قم
على استعداد للتعامل مع الصين الامر لا
يتعلق برابط الصين في لعب دور اكبر في
الشرق الاوسط لكن التغيرات في المنطقه وفي
السياسات الامريكيه منحت الصين الفرصه
لتكثيف نشاطها الدبلوماسي في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اداء الصين الجيد في ايران يرجع جزئيا الى
ان امريكا قد اتاحت لها المجال للقيام
بذلك كلما فرضنا عقوبات اكثر على ايران
اتجهت ايران نحو الصين اكثر من اتجاهها
نحو روسيا تتمتع الصين بقدره اكبر بكثير
من قدره الروس على التجاره مع ايران اذا
ما قررت الولايات المتحده وايران يوما ما
تطبيع علاقاتهما فسيكون ذلك اشبه بحالها
مع الدول العربيه ايست تحاول ايران ان
تكون على مسافه متساويه لكننا لم نصل الى
ذلك بعد
لكبح التوسع الاقتصادي والتكنولوجي للصين
في العالم اعلن قاده مجلس النواب الامريكي
في يناير 2022 عن مشروع قانون يهدف الى
تعزيز قدره امريكا على التنافس مع الصين
تضمن 52 مليار دولار لدعم تصنيع وابحاث
اشباه الموصلات
ويهدف قانون المنافسات الامريكي الى دعم
الصناعات الامريكيه لمجابهه الهيمنه
الصينيه
امريكا لم تواجه منافسا كالصين من قبل
بمعنى انها منافس لا يشاركه بعض حلفائنا
وحسب بل نحن انفسنا نشاركوه اقتصاديا
بعباره اخرى حجم تعاملنا الاقتصادي مع
الصين كبير واعتقد ان قدرا كبيرا من
المخاوف يتمحور حول تقدم الصين على امريكا
من الناحيه التكنولوجيه
بينما تعمل الصين على توسيع قوتها
الاقتصاديه في الشرق الاوسط فانها تنافس
امريكا ايضا بالقوه الناعمه ففي غضون
سنوات قليله توسعت شركات التكنولوجيا
الصينيه بسرعه في جميع انحاء العالم
وبدات في تحدي هيمنه الولايات المتحده في
مجالات التكنولوجيا والثقافه والترفيه
طريقه تانيه دايما بيتكلموا عليها اسمها
الانالوجس فكره الانالوجس اللي احنا بنبدا
نستخدم الوان قريبه من بعض على الكلر وي
والتلاته بيك علي خالد الحاصلوا على جائزه
افضل صانع محتوى تعليمي في عام 2022 على
تيك توك يعد من المؤثرين الاوسع شعبيه على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في مصر والشرق
الاوسط
وفقا لتقرير صدر عن كلاود فلير احدى اكبر
شبكات توصيل محتوى الانترنت فقد تفوق رابط
تيك توك الصيني على جوجل باعتباره النطاق
الاكثر زياره في العالم في العام 2021
طبعا التيك توك من الحاجات اللي فرقت جامد
جدا في مصر اغلب الجيل الجديد بالذات
الناس الصغيرين مهتمين جدا بتيك توك
وبيتفرجوا على تيك توك وهو دلوقتي نقدر
نقول السوشيال ميديا رقم واحد في مصر زي
مثلا فكره ان التيك توك في مديرين ناس
بتبقى شغاله بتتواصل مع الناس عاملين زي
كميونيتي او كده فابتدى مثلا اليوتيوب
يعمل شورتس ويحاول يخليها ويشغل ناس
ويبقوا زي التيك توك بالظبط نفس الكلام
الفيسبوك برضو ابتدى يشغل ناس تبدا تتواصل
مع الناس اللي بتعمل محتوى الانستجرام عمل
ريلز فكل الابليكيشنز دي بقت تتعلم من
التيك توك وتشوف هم بيعملوا ايه مميز
ويحاولوا يحطوه في السياسه بتاعتهم
اعتقدوا ان اي منصه تواصل اجتماعي في
الشرق الاوسط ستكون مساحه مهمه فاولا هناك
عدد غير قليل يقرب من 460 مليونا 300
مليون منهم يستخدمون وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
وكان لتيك توك تاثير لم ارى مثيلا له من
حيث تكيف المنصات الاخرى التي اصبحت تطرح
شكلا قريبا من شكل فيديو التيك توك اي
انها اخذت تتدافع لمواكبه تيك توك
[موسيقى]
2023 اعلن مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي خطه
لمواجهه نفوذ الصين المتنام في العالم
للحد من الاستثمارات وعمليات نقل
التكنولوجيا الى بيجن فيما اسماه محاولات
السيطره الصينيه على القرن الحادي
والعشرين معركه وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
مستمره فشعبيه تيك توك في الشرق الاوسط لم
تؤدي الى اختفاء المنصات الاخرى فالكثيرون
يستخدمون منصات متعدده ومره اخرى المبدعون
هم من يؤثرون على هذه المنصات اذا ما كان
هناك الكثير من المبدعين الصينيين
القادرين على نشر المحتوى الخاص بهم على
مستوى العالم فربما يكون لهم تاثير اكبر
من الناحيه الثقافيه
[موسيقى]
تقع افغانستان في اسيا الوسطى متاخمه
للشرق الاوسط ومجاوره للصين في اغسطس من
عام 2021 مرت افغانستان بمنعطف بالغ
الاهميه حيث انسحب الجيش الامريكي ايذانا
بنهايه حرب دامت 20 عاما عوده طالبان الى
السلطه جعلت من افغانستان ساحه جديده
للمنافسه بين الصين والولايات المتحده
ضابط متقاعد من وزاره الدفاع الصينيه
يتمتع بخبره كبيره في الدبلوماسيه
العسكريه هو يعتقد ان انسحاب الولايات
المتحده من افغانستان قد خلق فرصه هائله
للصين هل الشعب الافغاني ليست لديه ذكريات
سيئه تجاه الصينيين فالصينيون على الرغم
من كونهم جيرانا مباشرين لم يقدموا على
غزو افغانستان قط الصين كانت الثالثه اكبر
شريك تجاري خلال زمن الحرب في افغانستان
بعد ايران وباكستان فقط فاذا كانت الصين
هي ثالثه اكبر شريك تجاري لافغانستان
حينها اذا الان وقد انتهت الحرب فان لدينا
فرص افضل للاستثمار في افغانستان
[موسيقى]
في افغانستان 19 عاما كواحده من اوائل
رواد الاعمال الصينيين الذين ياتون الى
افغانستان للتجاره وهي اكبر بائع في
افغانستان لمعدات انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
النهارده
في الاشهر المزدهره جنيت حوالي 200 الف
دولار لكن بعد مجيء طالبان الى السلطه
وتراجع اداء الاقتصاد انخفضت مبيعاتي
بنسبه 70 الى 80%
[موسيقى]
بلد يعتمد اعتمادا كبيرا على ما يسمى بنقل
الدم من المجتمع الدولي فحوالي 75% من
الانفاق العام في الواقع مصدر التبرعات
الدوليه
لذا فاذا لم تمنح الشعب الافغانيه امواله
الخاصه وتسببت في موته فستكون هذه اقوى
جريمه في العالم
[موسيقى]
لقد بذلنا قصارى جهدنا وما زلنا نبذل كل
جهد ممكن لضمانه ازاله هذه القيود النقديه
ونواصل العمل على ازاله اكبر العقبات التي
تواجه طريق التنميه في افغانستان
لكن الامر يتطلب ايضا تدخل الحكومه
الصينيه لمساعدتنا
فاستثمارهم مهم لبلدهم ايضا
عوده الروابط الاقتصاديه بين الصين
وافغانستان يمكن ان تمهد الطريقه لعلاقات
اجتماعيه دائمه بين البلدين
اجتماعيه
[موسيقى]
عبد الرحمن
على الرغم من ان العقوبات الامريكيه تسبب
مشاكل اقتصاديه الا ان رجال الاعمال
الصينيين الذين يقدمون على المجازفه
يواصلون التدفق على افغانستان بحثا عن
الفرص من شاول قبل الدعوه صديق لحضور
اجتماع لرجال الاعمال الصينيين في كابول
الصين هي الدوله الاسرع نموا والاقوى في
المنطقه
الصين وافغانستان يحتاجان بشده الى تقويه
علاقاتهم الدبلوماسيه اولا ومن ثم الى
بناء علاقات الاقتصاديه
قد يؤدي الانسحاب الاستراتيجي الحالي
للولايات المتحده من افغانستان والشرق
الاوسط الى اتاحه الفرص امام الصين لكن
امريكا لا تزال تحتفظ بقبضه قويه في
المنطقه وتواصل ممارسه نفوذها كقوه عظمى
اعتقد ان امريكا لم تفقد مثل هذا نفوذ من
الاساس لكن دعنا نقول ان موقعها الممتده
قد تراجع الى الوضع الطبيعي في الشرق
الاوسط ومادام الدول الشرق الاوسط ترغب
ببقاء الولايات المتحده والولايات المتحده
على استعداد للقيام بذلك فانا لا ارى ان
نفوذ الولايات المتحده سيشهد مزيدا من
التراجع
تسعى الصين لبناء قوتها الاستراتيجيه في
المنطقه بتسريع الاستثمار بالقوه
الاقتصاديه والناعمه بالتزامن مع تعزيز
مكانتها السياسيه ما يشكل تهديدا لهيمنه
الولايات المتحده عالميه في ظل حشد امريكي
لحلفائها لتوثيق قواعد الائتلاف الغربي
وتبقى المعطيات الراهنه في حاله تجاذب
[موسيقى]
هذا وتجمع تحليلات امريكيه عديده على ان
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وفي القلب منها العالم
العربي ستكون محورا رئيسيا في صراع
المصالح بين الصين والولايات المتحده التي
ارتبطت التاريخيا بعلاقات شراكه وتحالف مع
العديد من دول المنطقه خاصه في الخليج
وتمتد علاقات الصين بدول المنطقه لعقود
النظر الا انها شهدت او شهدت زخما في
السنوات الاخيره فقد تاسس منتدى التعاون
الصيني العربي عام 2004 كاطار للتعاون
الجماعي في مجالات عديده الصين اطلقت عام
2016 وثيقه عن سياستها تجاه الدول العربيه
وتؤكد على الالتزام بمبادئ التعايش السلمي
والاحترام المتبادل للسياده والمساواه
والمنفعه المتبادله وركزت الوثيقه على
التعاون في مختلف المجالات فيما يخص
الطاقه البنيه التحتيه وكذا الاستثمار
والاقمار
خلال زياره الرئيس الصيني الى الرياض في
ديسمبر الماضي وقع اتفاقيه لشراكه
الاستراتيجيه مع السعوديه في قمه بين
البلدين ثلاثها قمه صينيه خليجيه وقمه
صينيه عربيه تعد الصين اكبر شريك تجاري
للدول العربيه مجتمعه بلغ حجم التبادل
التجاري بين الطرفين 400
مليار دولار العام الماضي فقط وبلغت
الاستثمارات الصينيه بالدول العربيه وربط
المئتين 214 مليار دولار ما بين 2005
2021 وهي بذلك اكبر مستثمر اجنبي في
العالم العربي انضمت احدى وعشرون دوله
عربيه الى مبادره الحزام والطريق الصينيه
وحمد بعضها الى مواءمه استراتيجيات
استراتيجيتها التنمويه مع هذه المبادره
التطور اللافت في الواقع كان نجاح وساطه
صينيه في مارس الماضي في التوصل الى اتفاق
بين ايران والسعوديه لاستئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بعد سبع سنوات من التوتر اثر
ذلك عرضت باجين القيامه بدور في توصيل
محادثات سلام بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين اما عسكريا فتشهد صادرات
السلاح الصينيه الى الدول العربيه تزايدا
ملحوظا في ظل رفض الولايات المتحده تصدير
بعض انواع الاسلحه للدول العربيه مثل
الطائرات المسيره وطائره اف 35
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا مشاهدينا الكرام كما نرحب
بضيفينا الكريمين معنا من عمان السامر خير
احمد الخبير في شؤون الصينيه ومؤلف كتاب
العرب ومستقبل الصين ومعنى من واشنطن
بريان مسؤول قسم اسيا بمعهد السلام
الامريكي ومستشار وزير الدفاع السابقه
المسؤوله عن امن اسيا والمحيط الهادئ نرحب
بضيفنا الكريمين لعلنا نبدا معك الدكتور
براين هاردينج وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
الذي كان في المنطقه وفي السعوديه تحديدا
منذ ايام يتوقع بعد ايام ان يكون متواجدا
في بيجين في زياره تاجلت بسبب ما تسميه
واشنطن ازمه بالون التجسس الصينيه الامر
الذي تنسيها الصين لكن ليس هذا فقط ما
يبقى عالقا بين الطرفين الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا ازمه تايوان والعديد من الملفات
الثقيله بين الطرفين لكن نتساءل حقيقه
ماذا في الصلب هذا الخلاف التنافس سميه ما
شئت بين بيجين و واشنطن
اولا اشكركم على اتاحه الفرصه لي واستمتعت
بالجزء السابق من البرنامج طبعا العلاقات
الصين الامريكيه معقد ولا يصير نحو
حلحله
القصه التي رايتموها
قدمت فرصه جيده لنفهم الموضوع المساله لا
تتعلق بالشرق الاوسط او جنوب اسيا وجنوب
شرق اسيا هي ذات بعد عالمي العلاقات
الامريكيه الصينيه البعض يرى فيها بعض
الدفئ لكن ما هو حقيقه عوده الى الحوار
والتواصل كلا الطرفين في سده السلطه في
واشنطن
يا ريان ان بامكاننا العلاقات ان تنزلق
الى منزلق خطر الولايات المتحده تحتاج الى
ما تقول هو دعامات صد لكي لا زحلقه
العلاقه الى منزلقه خطر اعتقد ان زياره
الرئيس عفوا الوزير بلنكن في راي فرصه
رائعه هذه اخبار طيبه لكن الاخبار السيئه
ان هناك ما تزال ازمه في كيفيه اداره هذه
العلاقه لدى رؤيه الطرفين لها لا شك ان
لقاء طرفين مهم جدا وقد يحلحل بعض الامور
لكن نتساءل حقيقه ما الذي تريده واشنطن
باعتقادك ما الذي او الرساله سيحملها وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي للطرف الصيني
لا هناك الكثير مما سيتم تحقيقه من منجزات
الصين تريد ان تقدم عن نفسها صوره طيبه
بانها مستعده للتعاون في امور مثل
التغيرات المناخيه وهو امر ضروري لكن اما
فيما يتعلق بالتوتر في تايوان او بحر جنوب
الصين والامور الصعبه اعتقد ان كل ما هناك
الان هو محاوله
لاطفاء وارسائي اسس حوار لكي لا تسير
الامور الى منزلقات خطره وايضا الزيارات
بين وزيرين الخارجيه او الرئيسين ضروريه
الان القوه في الصين متركزه بيد شي جنتين
وسيكون مهما ان يتحدث معه وزير الخارجيه
لكن نامل ان زياره وزير الخارجيه ستذوب
الجليد بين لكن العلاقه بين المؤسستين
العسكريتين يجب ان نضمن انها لا تؤدي الى
ازمه بين الطرفان ومن ثم تؤثر على منطقه
اسيا والعالم اجمع تحول الى ضيفي الكريم
من عمان سيد سامر خير احمد يعني لا شك ان
الصين هي ثاني اكبر اقتصاد في العالم تملك
قوه تكنولوجيه مبهره يقر بها العالم اجمع
هي لديها ايضا قوه عسكريه كبرى لديها الان
محاولات حتى على المستوى الدبلوماسي في
محاوله التوسط بين اطراف عديده في المنطقه
لكن نتساءل حقيقه هل يمكن ان تكون ندا
للمعسكر الغربي هل هذا كافي ليجعل منها
فعلا طرفا يمكن مناكفه المعسكر الغربي
وتحديدا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي
لها باع في المنطقه وفي كل العالم في
الواقع
مساء الخير حتى نتمكن من الاجابه على مثل
هذا السؤال المهم علينا ان نفهم كيف تفكر
الصين في الحقيقه الصين منذ وصل الرئيس
سجنبين الى السلطه في عام 2013 اخذ الصين
الى مرحله جديده تختلف تماما عن المرحله
السابقه التي تمتد منذ اطلاق سياسه
الاصلاح والانفتاح عام 1978 حتى نهايه عهد
عام 2013 الذي يجري في العالم اليوم ان
الصين تحاول تغيير شكل النظام العالمي
القائم من نظام احادي القطبيه تتزعم
الولايات المتحده وهو قائم في العالم منذ
نهايه الحرب البارده الى نظام متعدد
الاقطاب يكون فيه للصين دور مهم يكافئ دور
الولايات المتحده اذا الصين تريد ان تمد
نفوذها الى مناطق مختلفه من العالم ومنها
منطقه الشرق الاوسط لكنها لا تريد ان تحول
النظام العالمي الى نظام احادي القطبيات
تتزعممه هو يعني المنافسه بين الولايات
المتحده والصين الولايات المتحده تريد ان
تحافظ على شكل النظام العالمي القائم سنه
الصين تريده ان يصبح نظاما متعدد الاقطاب
بالتالي الصين لا تريد ان تحل محل
الولايات المتحده لكن الصين الذي تفعله
انها تستعمل مبادره الطريق والحزام التي
بدات تطبيقها منذ عام 2015 وثم صاغتها على
شكل فكره
مجتمع المصير المشترك للبشريه الذي من
خلاله تستطيع الصين تقول انها تريد ان
تستفيد من ثمار التنميه ونجاح الاقتصادي
المستمر منذ عقود عديده لفائده الدول
الناميه بهذه اللغه التي الدبلوماسيه التي
تتحدث فيها الصين تجاه العالم وتحديدا
تجاه الدول الناميه ومنها الدول العربيه
هي تقول انها من خلال العمل الاقتصادي
المشترك والمشاريع المشتركه يمكن ان نبني
مستقبلا جديدا لكن الولايات المتحده تحذر
في المقابل ان هذه المبادره الصينيه وهذا
السلوك الصيني الذي ظاهره اقتصادي وباطنه
سياسي سوف يؤثر على الامن العالمي اذا
منطقه الشرق الاوسط هي واحده من ساحات
المنافسه بين الطرفين هناك اعتبارات عديده
لهذا الامر ليس فقط التنافس العالمي وانما
ايضا هناك خصوصيه لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط
واهم ما في هذه الخصوصيه هي موضوع النفط
لان
العلاقه الامريكيه بالمنطقه تستند على
النفط على مدار العقود الطويله الماضيه
ايضا اهتمامها بهذه المنطقه باعتبارها
مصدر اساسي للنفذ الدكتور باين نقاط مهمه
اشار اليها ضيفنا الكريم من عمان السيد
سامر خير احمد قد نصل الى منطقه الشرق
الاوسط لكن قبلها اود ان اعرف ما ذكره عن
ان الصين لا تريد ان تكون في مواجهه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولا ندا لها
لكن تريد عالم متعدد الاقطاب الان هناك
محاولات صينيه للحصول على حلفاء كثر تقارب
الصيني الروسي ربما هو من بين اكثر ما
يزعج الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نود ان
نعرف ونسمع منك يعني كيف ترى ربما واشنطن
هذا التقارب بين الطرفين هناك المناورات
عسكريه انتقدتها مؤخرا هناك العديد من
اوجه التعاون بين الطرفين
اعتقد ان واشنطن اضافه للعواصف في اوروبا
وفي اليابان قلقه للغايه حول عمليه تطبيع
العلاقات بين روسيا
والصين طبعا هناك حديث عن شركات في الشرق
الاوسط ايضا تذكر ان الام لا يتعلق والصيد
فحسب في اسيا هناك عدد من البلدان الحليفه
للولايات المتحده قلقه
بصعود الصين والعدوانيه الصينيه في بحر
جنوب الصين
تقول الامر يمكن ان يكون على اساس اننا
نتفاهم وتسير الامور على ما يرام لكن واقع
الحال يقول ان هناك عدد من البلدان لا
تريد ان تعيش في عالم مركزيته قطبيه صينيه
لهذا السبب الصين تركز على الجانب المالي
هي لا تريد تاخذ دورا قياديا في الشرق
الاوسط لكن في ظل التنافس الصيني الامريكي
الشرق الاوسط له مكانه لكن الولايات
المتحده والصين يتنافسان في اماكن مثل
الجنوب اسيا وجنوب شرق اسيا منطقه المحيط
الهادئ لكن
الانخراط الامريكي هناك يزداد الشرق
الاوسط هو بيئه مثيره للاهتمام لان النفوذ
الامريكيه تراجع والنفوذ الصيني يتزايد
العلاقه بين الولايات المتحده والصين يمكن
ان يلعب دور ثنائيه قطبيه فاذا اقطاب اخرى
مثل الاتحاد الاوروبي ودوران في المنطقه
دور مصر في المنطقه
بامكانها المتحده ان يتعاملها بطريقه
مثمره ربما اكثر من اماكن اخرى اقرب هي
للصين الجغرافيه من الجيد انك تشير الى
هذه النقطه المتعلقه منطقتنا الشرق الاوسط
رئيس بايدن خلال زيارته الى جده في الصيف
الماضي قال بهذه الكلمات لن نترك فراغا
لمنافسين الاستراتيجيين في المنطقه يعني
الجميع يعلم بان الولايات المتحده ان لم
تكن قد انسحبت صراحه كما حدث في افغانستان
والعراق فانها لم تعد بتلك بذلك التواجد
في منطقتنا وبالتالي السؤال الن تستغل
الصين فعليا هذا الفراغ من عده طرق كما
ذكرنا اقتصاديه نعم تكنولوجيه عسكريه لكن
الان الجانب السياسي ايضا بدات تحدث
مبادرات
وربما نوع من الوساطات للصين في دول
المنطقه
كانت منخرطه بشكل مكثف في الشرق الاوسط في
العشرين عاما الماضيه لكن هذا القصه لم
تكن دائما قصه سعيده نعمات المتحده انهت
وجودها في افغانستان بطريقه لم تكن
تتمناها ومثير للاهتمام ان نرى ان الصين
بدات تدخل وهذه ليست بوادر جيده اذا ما
رجعنا الى دروس التاريخ اما قصه ان الصين
استطاعت التوسط بين ايران والسعوديه هي
مثيره للاهتمام لكن هي في نفس الوقت محل
فضول ومحل امل من المفيد ان تكون هناك قوه
خارجيه حتى لو كانت الصين تحقق درجه من
الاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط في وقت انخراط
المتحده يبدو في انحطاط وتراجع نسبه لكن
ايضا هناك نقطه مهمه الوقت المتحده
اعظم خارطه في الشرق الاوسط بشكل كبير من
ناحيه التاثير وايضا من ناحيه
التدخل والانخراط الصيني يتزايد لكن
المتحده تركز على التنافس العالمي مع
الصين اكثر لكن الانخراط الامريكي بشكل
عام في منطقه المحيط الهندي والهادي مكثفه
ولزاها كل الاسباب لذلك الولايات المتحده
قوه عظمى قويه لكن ايضا بالنسبه للنمو
الاقتصادي والتاريخ هذا القرن سيتم كتابته
بشكل كبير في المحيط الهادي واسيا والهند
جنوب وشمال المحيط الهادي لهذا السبب
اعتقد المتحده تركز اكثر فاكثر على الصين
والشرق اسيا لكنها تفكر بطريقه اوسع نطاقا
الفلبين وفي اندونيسيا بقوه اخرى وهذه
التوجهات في السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
وهي تركيز الاهتمام بجنوب اسيا والامر لا
يتعلق دائما بنديه هناك ايضا بعد الشراكه
في الوقت الذي تتعمق فيه
الخراصات امريكا في الجنوب اسيا هذه المره
لا المتحده على خلاف العشرين عاما الماضيه
تفعل ذلك بمشاركه اوروبيه اكثر من كونها
بمعزل عن اوروباط المتحده تبقى قوه عالميه
والشرق الاوسط سيبقى جزءا من ذلك لكن واضح
ان الانخراط الامريكي يتجه شرقا في وقت
تتزايد في اهتمامات الصين بالشرق الاوسط
يعني مهم جدا الكلام الذي تقوله السيد
ساميه سمعت ذكره ضيفنا الكريم من واشنطن
ان الولايات المتحده ما يهمها الان توجه
شرقا اكثر مع بقاء الاهتمام بهذه المنطقه
لكن الصين تضع بكل ثقلها في هذه المنطقه
والسؤال حقيقه ما اسباب ما سر هذا
الاهتمام الصيني منطقه الشرق الاوسط
والعالم العربي يعني تحديدا يعني تجلى ذلك
في سلسله من القمم الصينيه في السعوديه
اواخر العام الماضي قمه سعوديه صينيه قمه
خليجيه صينيه اخيرا قمه عربيه صينيه نهيكه
عن الناس الصيني لعلاقات تمتد من المشرق
العربي الى المغرب الى اقصى المغرب العربي
ما السر وراء ذلك ما الذي تريده فعلا
الصين من هذه الجغرافيا الممتده للعالم
العربي
نعم هناك عده اعتبارات لتعامل الصين مع
المنطقه العربيه لكن لنفهم الموضوع بشكل
اوسع دعنا دعنا نضع الامر في سياقه
الحقيقي
الاستراتيجيه الامن القومي الامريكيه
تتحدث عن الرضع المتكامل تجاه الصين لذلك
الموضوع ليس اهتمام الصين او اهتمام
الولايات المتحده بهذه المنطقه او تلك
المساله هي تنافس عالمي بين هاتين القوتين
الولايات المتحده تريد ان تحافظ على
النظام العالمي القائم الصين تريد ان تغير
النظام العالمي القائم لذلك الولايات
المتحده قامت بالضغط على الصين على مدار
العامين الفائتين منذ وصول جو بايدن الى
البيت الابيض عبر عده محاور اولا من
الناحيه العسكريه قامت بنشر قواتها في غرب
المحيط الهادئ ونفذت العديد من المناورات
العسكريه مع اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه على
وجه الخصوص واقامت العديد من
القواعد العسكريه الجديده بالتعاون مع
الفلبين ونشرت قوتها على شواطئ استراليا
اذا هناك حشد عسكري في غرب المحيط الهادئ
في مواجهه الصين وكذلك الصين قامت بتنفيذ
مناورات عسك
[موسيقى]
فلهذا كله ان هذه المنطقه التي هي منطقه
نفوس تقليدي للولايات المتحده تحاول الصين
ان تهرب الى الامام من خلال التدخل فيها
لتبادل الضغط السياسي مع الولايات المتحده
لان الولايات المتحده
الان منصب على اقصى الشرق هل ما كان
ملموسا ولا مساء الجميع من انسحاب امريكي
من المنطقه او عدم اهتمام كما كان في
السابق للمنطقه سيتكرس ويستمر وبالتالي
نرى تصاعدا للدور الصيني اقتصاديا نعم لكن
عسكريا ايضا وسياسيا من خلال الوساطات
التي رايناها
الذي يجري حتى الان يشي بان هذا من الممكن
ان يحصل لان مثلا زياره بلينكن قبل ايام
الى السعوديه قالت وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه ان الوزير الامريكي لم يتمكن من
شرح وجهه نظر الولايات المتحده تجاه ما
تراه خطرا من تقارب السعوديه مع الصين لان
السعوديه اعتبرت ان ذلك
مساله تمس الامن الوطني السعودي او يعني
تمص السياده السعوديه فبالتالي
السعوديه على وجه الخصوص تتجه لبناء شراكه
استراتيجيه مع الصين وهذا امر غير مسبوق
يعني لانه يتجاوز العلاقات التجاريه
الاقتصاديه التقليديه المبنيه فقط على
مبادره الطريق والحزام للدخول في شراكه
استراتيجيه من ذلك مثلا ان الصين ساعدت
السعوديه وما تزال تساعد السعوديه على
انشاء مصنع للصواريخ الباليستيه بالقرب من
الرياض هذا التطور مهم جدا في العلاقه
السعوديه الصينيه وكذلك
وزير الاستثمار
للاسف انقطع الاتصال مع ضيفنا الكريم
السيد سامر خير نتحول الى ضيفنا الكريم
يعني كنت تتحدث يبدو ان السيد سامر قد عاد
الينا نود ان تكمل فكرتك لو تكرمت
للاسف انقطع الاتصال سنعود الاتصال بالسيد
سامر لكنني اتحول للدكتور
هاردينج كنت تقول بان الاهتمام الاكبر
الان للولايات المتحده سينصب على اقصى
الشرق ما الذي يعنيه ذلك يعني هل ربما
منطقه الشرق الاوسط لم تعد بتلك الاهميه
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه انعكس
ذلك في السنوات الماضيه لكن اود ان نعرف
ما الذي يمكن ان يماثله ذلك فعليا ولد
الولايات المتحده شركاء مهمون في هذه
المنطقه
الولايات المتحده ما تزال تعتبر الشرق
الاوسط منطقه مهمه وهناك قوس جغرافي يمتد
من اوروبا حتى شرق اسيا والشرق الاوسط هو
جزء من هذه المنظومه الدوليه والاستقرار
في الشرق الاوسط مهم للاستقرار العالمي
والنمو والامن في العالم هناك شعور عام
بان الولايات المتحده ربما انخرطت بشكل
زائد عن اللزوم في السابق بسبب بعض ما
قامت المتحده من حرب العراق وغير ذلك وان
الفرس لم تكن هناك بالضروره لكن هناك
امتداد كبير للوجود الامريكي في المنطقه
وهناك جيل من الدبلوماسيين الذين طوروا
خبرات عظيمه في هذه المنطقه وقاده عسكريين
وهناك وجود عسكري الامريكي لا يستهان
المنطقه وبامكان روتار المتحده ان تنتج ما
تحتاجه من الطاقه والطاقه مساله عالميه
والشرق الاوسط بعد مهم من ابعاد مساله
الطاقه وهي مهمه ايضا لحلفاء امريكا مثل
اليابان وغيرها لهذا السبب الوتر المتحده
لابد لها من ان تطور
وتعمق من انخراطها في الشرق الاوسط لكن
اين ستضع تلك القدره الدبلوماسيه الاضافيه
والبعث الدور الاضافيه هذا سيعني انها
ستذهب الى الى اسيا لكن لا يعني بالضروره
ان الشرق الاوسط لم يعد مهمه يعني حاله
التجاذب الراهن في الواقع الموجوده وسؤالي
ابقى مع الدكتور
بين القوى الكبرى الصين روسيا وقوه صاعده
اخرى مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
نتساءل حقيقه الى متى ستستمر والى ماذا
يمكن ان تؤدي
نعم هذه حاله من
مكابده
تحدثتم على الولايات المتحده وحلفائها انا
ساركز على كلمه حلفائها عندما نتحدث عن
منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ اليابان
والفلبين وكوريا الجنوبيه كلها كلهم
مشغولون
وقلقون بموضوع الصين وايضا كيف تنظر
اوروبا الان الى مساله المخاطر التي تنتج
عن الصين في العشر سنوات الماضي القضيه
ليست فقط قضيه امريكا والصين وامريكا
وروسيا تحدثنا عن تايوان مثلا وهذا برهان
اخر على كيف ان النظام الدولي عالمي وممتد
بالاسيا واوروبا وكيف ان اللعبه النهائيه
كيف ستؤثر مساله اوكرانيا على ما يحدث يا
حيوان بالتاكيد
ان اوكرانيا استطاعت ان تنجح في مسعها
بدعم من امريكا
وحلفائها الاوروبيين وبعض حلفائها
الاوروبيين وحلفائها في الشرق بدعم من
العقوبات نظام العقوبات عروسها هذا سيكون
له اثر على صيد طبعا نرى ان
سيؤثر على تايوان مجموعه صغيره تعيش في ظل
نظام ديمقراطي لو استطاعت الصين ان تاخذ
لربما تفعل ذلك لان كل ما يحدث في مكان ما
في العالم له تداعيات في اماكن اخرى
والنظر الى القوى العظمى مثل امريكا
والصين وروسيا لا يعني اننا ننسى دور
الحلفاء الاخرين لان هناك شبه شبكه رائعه
من التحالفات وانظروا ايضا الى تحالفات
الصين في العالم بعض البلدان المعزوله
كوريا الشماليه ايران ايضا السبب ان كما
بحثنا
وعلاقاتها وعزلتها ايضا وليس لديها الصين
واضح يعني نتساءل حقيقه وسؤالي الان للسيد
سامر خير احمد جاهزا معنا مره اخرى نتساءل
عن وضع الصين العالمي كيف يمكن ان يكون اي
شكل سيمكن ان يتخذه اذا ما نجحت في تنفيذ
المبادره التي وضعت فيها ثقل كبير
المتعلقه بالحزام والطريق واحياء طريق
الحرير القديم هذه المبادره التي انضمت
اليها العديد من الدول العربيه نتحدث عن
اكثر من عشرين دوله
الصين لديها خطه معلنه على الناحيه
الاقتصاديه تريد ان تستعمل مبادره الطريق
والحزام لتحقيقها وهي تنقسم الى مرحلتين
المرحله الاولى تنتهي في عام 2035 وهدفها
كما تقول الصين تحديث الاشتراكيه الصينيه
يعني تحديث الاقتصاد الداخلي
ورفاهيه الشعب الصيني والامكانيات
الحياتيه داخل الصين والمرحله الثانيه
تمتد حتى عام 2099 التي هي مئويه تاسيس
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه وفيها تريد الصين
ان تصبح قوه مؤثره من الناحيه الدوليه وان
تصبح القوه الاقتصاديه الاولى في العالم
لذلك النجاح الصين في تنفيذ مبادره الطريق
والحزام هي بالنسبه لها الضمانه لتحقيق
هذه الاهداف الاقتصاديه كل العمل السياسي
الصيني الذي بدا منذ وصول سيجنبين الى
السلطه يقوم على مفاتيح اقتصاديه في
الاساس
ولذلك كان البرنامج الاساسي الذي قدمه منذ
ان اصبح رئيسا هو مبادره الطريق والحزام
التي تقوم على استثمار نحو تريليون
دولار امريكي في مشاريع البناء التحتيه
وتطوير الموانئ وتطوير شبكات النقل في نحو
140 دوله من العالم وتقول الصين انها حتى
حلول عام 2030 هذه
المبالغ الطائله التي سوف تستثمرها في هذه
البلدان ستنتج
واحد فاصله سته تريليون دولار يعني هناك
فوائد ماليه وارباح سوف تجنيها الصين من
ناحيه وسوف تجنيها الدول الشركه لها هكذا
تقول الصين لذلك النجاح الصين في تنفيذ
مبادره الطريق والحزام يعني انها ستصبح
القوه الاقتصاديه الاولى في العالم ويعني
ايضا انها ستؤثر على شكل النظام العالمي
القائم وستصبح قوه دوليه مؤثره لذلك
الولايات المتحده تخشى الاستكمال هذه
المبادره ووصولها الى اهدافها وهناك وسائل
امريكيه عديده تتخذها في محاوله التصدي
لهذه المباراه الاخير وفي عجاله لو تكرمت
الان علاقه البلدين الى تهدئه ام الى مزيد
من التصعيد باعتقادك
ساكون متفائلا واقول اننا
من الجيد ان الوزير بلانكن سيزور الصين
نحن نحتاج الى ضمانات لكي لا اتحول هذا
الحوار او هذا العلاقة شيء لا يريده اي من
الطرفين وهو مواجهه غير مرغوب فيها وان
نتجاوز حده الموقف اشكر جزيل الشكر ضيفي
الكريمين من واشنطن
بالمعهد السلام الامريكي واشكر جزيل الشكر
ضيفي من عمان سامر خير احمد الخبير في
شؤون الصينيه ومؤلف كتاب العرب ومستقبل
الصين
ختاموا حلقتنا هذه من برنامجنا قصه باقيا
نعود ونلقاكم باذن الله مع بقيه لقصه
جديده الاثنين القادم ان شاء الله السلام
عليكم
[موسيقى]